cap sur le biais de marne asie du sud
est un pays plongé en pleine crise
politique lundi dernier sans crier gare
l'armée procède d'un coup d'état
alléguant des fraudes électorales
massives aung san suu kyi chef du
gouvernement civil depuis 2016 est à
rétribuer ou responsables vertement
condamné par la communauté
internationale
ce putsch militaire est saluée par des
sympathisants de la mouvance cuban qui
voit plutôt un exemple à suivre
alors jeff le lointain yanmar et la
mouvance qui ont un a priori c'est un
peu contre intuitif on médine ou comment
on réagit certains sympathisants qui ont
amené certains conspirationnistes en
voyant ça ils ont accueilli le coup
d'état
les bronzes ouvert on a même dit que
c'est une bonne chose on souhaite que ça
arrive aux états unis voudraient que
c'est quand même difficile de pauvres
les parallèles ont dit qu avance l'armée
birmane et la position du cadre d'un
autre champion telles élections de
novembre donc on avance des fraudes
électorales massives des millions de
votes invalidés donc l'armée a décidé de
déposer la cheffe des termes sens
dessous dessus en disant qu'elle n'est
pas légitime parce que l'élection ait
été truquée et ben dans la mouvance qu
on en dise qu'on dit en gros c'est voici
un pays qui agit de la bonne manière on
aurait dû faire ça aux états unis on dit
peut-être même que c'est un précurseur
que l'armée américaine va s'inspirer de
ce qui s'est passé au myanmar
ils vont procéder à la dépose et le
président joe biden
donc ça peut sembler surprenant que qui
aux amandes s'intéresse à ce qui se
passe au myanmar
mais on établit très rapidement des
parallèles avec ce qu'ils croient se
passait aux états unis en ce moment oui
en plus de ça jeff ya même l'histoire de
dominer un système qui revenue à la
faveur des événements au myanmar dans le
discours des adeptes de cloyne web et ou
comment avec l'élection américaine de
novembre donc avec l'élection américaine
en avait
ah les geeks une entreprise ça peut être
deux millions de volumes système ce qui
crée des machines pour comptabiliser les
votes avaient procédé au trucage de
l'élection et une autre entreprise mais
indique où on avait avancé la même chose
et puis l'homme ont dit combien de morts
ces entreprises ont fait la même chose
qu aux etats unis ils ont truqué les
résultats du vote
ils ont procédé toute sorte de
manigances pause pour aung san suu kyi
gang l'élection le problème avec ça
c'est que le myanmar au fait un vote à
l'ancienne donc dès votre papier il n'y
a pas de machines comme aux états unis
le vote est pas enregistrés sur de façon
numérique donc ça ne tient pas debout
bien sûr tu attends de voir des complots
partout voire une cabale tedo satanique
partout donc on insiste on a tenté
d'associer l'administration dans san suu
kyi à l'administration du président
barack obama et de hillary clinton
l'ancien opposant de dos rond pendant
que tout ça ça fait partie d'une cabale
et que ce qui est à vous maintenant
c'est un signal de ce qui s'en vient aux
états unis encore leur sans offrir
aucune preuve
puis d'autres faits il ya aussi facebook
on ne peut pas ne pas en parler jeff un
gros véhicule de désinformation gagnent
marc webb facebook avait procédé à faire
fermer des comptes associés à l'armée du
myanmar il ya quelques années des
comptes qui aurait peut-être même
fomenté la haine envers la minorité
india dans ce pays le et l'alarmé audi
fermé l'accès à facebook dans le pays
pour au moins sept jours donc ça irait
jusqu'à dimanche
ça va être à suivre parce qu'il ya un
contrôle de l'information assez massif
pour dire combien mort pour beaucoup de
gens facebook c'est l'internet donc les
gens utilisent facebook pour s'envoyer
des messages et et pour s'informer mais
pas juste comme nous on fait ici comme
beaucoup de gentillesse facebook pour
bien des gens bien de marc s'éviter tout
l'internet passe par facebook ne vivons
pas sur d'autres sites ils vont rester
dans facebook donc le fait de fermer
facebook c'est décrié par beaucoup
d'activistes au myanmar et beaucoup
d'organismes internationaux qui disent
qu'il ya quand même un danger a ainsi de
contrôler l'information de cette façon
là
quinze mille kilomètres séparent wash
actuel de rangueil principale baie du
myanmar peu pays à peine sorti d'un demi
siècle de régimes militaires
et pourtant malgré la distance et des
contextes très différents certains
discours politiques se ressemblent au
myanmar le parti soutenu par l'armée a
subi une cuisante défaite aux élections
générales de novembre dernier et depuis
là-bas aussi le refrain de la fraude
électorale massive se fait entendre sur
fond de désinformation jean-françois
rancourt bonjour bienvenue décrypteurs
jour vous vous êtes rendus sur place au
mieux demain à quelques reprises déjà
2014 2018 2020 vous connaissez bien le
pays
dites-nous est ce que ça vous surprend
ce qui s'est produit au cours
d'audiences semaine là-bas et si on
procède & clank de la désinformation
qu'est ce que vous avez à nous dire pour
reprendre d'abord niveau surpris je
voudrais que c'est une demi surprise à
quelque part il ya eu des signes avant
coureurs d'un coup pouvaient être mises
en place on a eu justement des des
communications par rapport à celle de la
semaine dernière
comme quoi les militaires menacé de le
faire donc disons qu'on l'anticipait un
peu mais on espérait quand même
peut-être un peu naïvement que ça se
produirait pas au niveau de la
désinformation une des choses justement
c'est par rapport à ce qui a été dit sur
les intentions des militaires il ya eu
évidemment bon les les communiqués
officiels mais il ya beaucoup
d'informations qui circulent sur les
réseaux sociaux par rapport à la
situation était nominé mort et soit
c'est contradictoire et celle des
informations elle est attribuable à qui
au juste à l'armée elle même directement
effectivement oui l'armée a été très
engagé dans la désinformation sur les
réseaux sociaux on sait qu'ils ont
littéralement un bureau qui travaillent
à publier des choses sur internet à
mettre en place des réseaux trop content
même si ses comptes ce fonds bloqués
elles trouvent souvent le moyen d'en
créer de nouveaux et de s'attirer à
nouveau une grande base d'utilisateurs
qui les suivent et qui relaie ensuite
ces informations erronées
donc on comprend que l'élection du mois
de novembre s'était soldé par une
défaite cuisante du parti soutenu par
les militaires comment dans ce cas là la
désinformation s'est progressivement mis
en place selon vous est ce qu'on a vu
dans les messages des militaires
ressemble énormément disco qui était
propagé chez nos voisins du sud aux
états unis
on soutient que donato homme qui disait
que les élections étaient une énorme
fraude c'est exactement le message que
les militaires ont lancé suite aux
élections de novembre dernier ont mis à
mort ils ont affirmé qu'ils avaient près
d'une dizaine de millions de bulletins
de vote qui était erroné
alors que donc au point de vue des
observateurs internationaux il ya eu une
déclaration récemment l'union européenne
s'est de suite et 95 cents les
organismes qui ont observé les élections
juge qu'elle était bonne ou très bonne
donc absolument rien qui vient confirmer
ces affirmations le des militaires donc
oui les réseaux sociaux sont porteurs de
cette désinformation de se re en cours
mais en contrepartie il offre une
possibilité de mobilisation non pour
ceux qui s'opposent aux militaires et à
la désinformation que ce que vous
observez un chapitre là oui c'est une
nouvelle variable en fait dans
l'histoire du myanmar c'est pas la
première fois qu'il coup d'état
militaire malheureusement mais c'est la
première fois que ça se produit dans un
contexte où les médias sociaux ont
largement pénétré la population
juste pour vous illustrer un peu en 2011
seulement un pour cent de la population
pays avaient accès à internet
aujourd'hui en 2020 plus tôt on parlait
de 41% de la population c'est incroyable
comme os et donc on le vit dans les
précédents jours un mouvement de
résistance civile s'est organisée
lorsque le couvre-feu tombe à 20 heures
passent maintenant il ya un couvre-feu
dans tout le pays les gens sortent et
tape sur leurs casseroles font du bruit
klaxons avec la voiture mais si les gens
ont pu commencer à répandre ce mouvement
là c'est notamment grâce aux réseaux
sociaux qui leur ont permis de créer des
groupes de répandre le message
énormément de hashtag des messages qui
sont diffusés des milliers fois en ce
moment
des plateformes des réseaux sociaux sont
vraiment ceux qui gardent les gens
connectés mais le risque c'est que les
militaires décident à nouveau de couper
les communications internet comme elles
l'ont fait le premier jour du coup
d'état
sur un court merci pour ces explications
et 11e prochaine ou décrypteurs à revoir
au revoir